le gouvernement a présenté ce matin un
projet de loi très attendu pour lutter
contre l'exclusion il sera discuté dès
le mois de mai et concerne directement
trois millions de français indirectement
6 millions avec leurs familles il en
coûtera 22 milliards à l'état d'ici l'an
2000 ce projet s'attache essentiellement
résoudre les problèmes de l'emploi du
surendettement et du logement
pour ce qui concerne l'emploi d'abord le
point essentiel consiste à encourager le
travail aux dépens de l'as système ainsi
toute personne qui aura trouvé un
travail à temps partiel pourra désormais
cumuler pendant un an de manière
dégressive et rémy allocations diverses
et son nouveau salaire laurent bailly
daniel green it mais elle travaille
quand même en moyenne 18 heures par
semaine comme réceptionniste dans cet
hôtel droit el khamissi un peu plus de
2000 francs par mois une somme qui est
automatiquement des buts de son hernie
car le système actuel interdit
d'additionner le revenu minimum
d'insertion avec un revenu salarial
clair le gagne d'écrire de plus avec
sept ans pour atteindre même si je ne
travaillais pas mais je préfère
travailler parce que je garde un petit
d'entreprise pour moi et on est
important de connaître les rouages de
l'entreprise
et puis mon travail accompli pour sa
retraite son temps libre clair le
consacre à la recherche d'un travail
mieux payés et moins précaire et
fréquentes notamment cette association
d'insertion où elle peut consulter des
offres d'emploi il n'est pas rare que
al'inverse de claire des chômeurs
refusent des petits boulots à temps
partiel parce qu'ils l'ont vite il rien
à y gagner
touchant de mise le rapport précisant à
chaque mois c'est un problème il relate
un entretien à lire ou déclaré lauda ils
ont donc touché un peu moins de rémy est
donc finalement rmistes démotivés à
cause d'un système trop rigide clair
elle a son opinion sur la question
l'idéal serait que le fmi puisse venir
en complément du salaire mais que donc à
la fin on touche le salaire plus leurs
amis dans sa globalité devra combien
dans votre cas après le tour de ce que
j'ai tellement ça ferait sa voisine un
espoir bientôt réaliser la réforme
envisagée permettra ainsi d'éviter des
montants de l'air et mis aussi
dérisoires que celui-ci 157e rang au
moins pendant quelques mois
le projet prévoit également un programme
particulier d'insertion de 18 mois pour
les jeunes les plus défavorisés ils sont
environ 60 milles en france il s'agit de
leur permettre d'acquérir des
connaissances de base et une
qualification professionnelles le
président du milk a insisté ce matin sur
un point il estime que les aides
publiques ne doivent pas des avantages
et ceux qui travaillent
deuxième point de ce projet de loi le
problème des personnes et des ménages
surendettés les commissions spécialisées
pourront désormais étalée le règlement
des dettes sur huit ans au lieu de cinq
et un moratoire de trois ans pourra même
être déclarées avant une éventuelle
effacement des dettes
chaque câble en faire l'objet d'une
étude particulière
reportage elisabeth à deux pas de lille
les deux mules y ont fait concernant
maison
à ce moment là il ne vivait pas dans le
clan mais avec un salaire et les
allocations familiales pour 3 d'enfants
ils pouvaient rembourser leurs crédits
sans problème la france l'avait prévu
les frais supplémentaires pour finir la
maison ni du chômage partiel deux gènes
ouvrier dans l'automobile par semaine a
passé quinze jours j'ai perdu facilement
2030 mon salaire mensuel en 90 ils ne
peuvent plus faire face
une fois les deux francs bourse et il ne
leur reste que 1200 francs pour vivre
ils sont at-elle à la commission de
surendettement de ville
elle se réunit chaque semaine sous les
lambris du grand chalon de la banque de
france
quarante dossiers sont examinés ce matin
le nord pas de calais et la région la
plus touchée par le surendettement
il y a là un phénomène qui s'est
installée au sein de la société
française et qui concerne de plus en
plus ce qu'on peut appeler les
accidentés de la vie
c'est à dire les particuliers les
ménages qui sont frappés soit par la
perte de mon emploi le chômage soit par
le dijonnais ont perdu toute la maison
ont perdu
c'est parce que leurs plus grosses bêtes
été reporté tous les deux mulliez on
veut garder leur maison et tout c'est
grâce à leurs filles aînées elle est
étudiante mais travaille pendant toutes
ses vacances pour aider les familles en
ligne on est là on essaye d'être content
d'être joyeux et vous même sur la fin
problème on essaye quand même de les
infos les oublier et quand on est une
famille ce qui est important ils sont
tous convaincus se battre ensemble
c'est encore la meilleure façon de
résister à l'exclusion troisième point
le logement encore si le projet de loi
est adopté les expulsions de locataires
qui ne peuvent pas payer leurs loyers
seront interdits tant que le relogement
ne sera pas assurée par ailleurs tout
conclure d'eau ou d'électricité seront
interdits dans les cas elle est plus
difficile on estime à environ 110 mille
le nombre d'expulsions demandé en france
chaque année
enfin le volet santé du plan contre
l'exclusion ne sera examiné qu'en 1999
il fait froid
l'institution d'une couverture maladie
universelle procès de maurice parent
prend une nouvelle fois suspendu
l'ancien ministre ayant appris la nuit
dernière la mort de sa femme de 88 ans
le président du tribunal a accepté que
les plaidoiries ne reprennent que lundi
prochain
dominique verdeilhan alertés vers 2
heures du matin du décès de son épouse
maurice papon a quitté bordeaux en
voiture pour regagner sa maison de gretz
armainvilliers dans la région parisienne
au même moment stoïque quelques
bordelais attendre pour une audience qui
n'aura pas lieu
en guise d'avis de décès le simple
affichette à nice le report du procès le
visage fermé et jean marc varaut se
refuse à tout commentaire
la pudeur de maurice papon doit être la
nôtre seront ses seuls mots à l'audience
connaissez sa résolution son caractère
et dans le malheur qui est le sien il
entend assumer toutes ses
responsabilités
il sera donc présent à l'audience de
l'aide du côté des victimes personne ne
songe à s'offusquer de ce nouveau report
de ce nouveau contretemps un cas de
force majeure est un signe du destin
victime et accusée vivent des douleurs
similaire est aujourd'hui chacun pense à
ces morts nous on a fait face
malheureusement ma ne connaissent un
déficit de ses cultures
donc premier triste le pilote a
intervient à quelques jours du verdict
ce drame ce deuil de l'accusé peuvent
ils rendre plus clément 12 jurés
les parties civiles ne veulent pas se
croiser les jurés ont déjà d'arbres y
arriver et ça m'inquiète pas bon c'est
un incident
supplémentaire à ce procès et je pense
que pour le verbe et qui a pas du tout à
ça a été ma volonté prime sur mon état
physique a souvent répété au cours de
son procès maurice papon
ce soir il reste à bordeaux une inconnue
sa capacité à réagir à un tel choc
la suite du procès et un verdict attendu
par les victimes
en défendant suite des élections open
lance des conseils régionaux l'udf
continuent de se déchirer même si
aujourd'hui
finalement à la main de là après
françois de tarés françois bayrou a
finalement demandé aux cinq présidents
idec lui grâce au relais front national
de démissionner car ils sont utiles dans
l'impossibilité de gérer leur fin pour
l'heure même si certains d'entre eux
réfléchissent aucun a annoncé
effectivement cette démission
enfin ce soir c'est françois bayrou qui
annonce lui-même son intention de créer
un nouveau parti pour remplacer du dr
j'habite à berre françoise est ce
mauvais pas ce qui comptait encore pour
alain madelin c'était la survie de
l'idée c'est pourquoi son propre parti
démocratie libérale qui en est une des
composantes est rentré dans le rang
il y avait une consigne léotard des
présidents de région et lui par son
effet mais missionné qu'il y aura une
possibilité mais il faudrait mettre les
j'ai mal au coeur quand je vois si
pancartes qui vous est grande que les
visions millions et quelques plats peau
nous rions l'épave avons nyon est un
homme d'honneur qui ne pourra pas
gouverner sa région et qui doit en tirer
les conséquences
charles millon justement doit en
principe rencontrer valéry giscard
d'estaing demain pour prendre conseil
auprès de l'ancien chef de l'état
mais que faire avec les présidents de
région qui annonce clairement la couleur
exemple jacques blanc est venu ce matin
à la réunion lui même élu avec l'appoint
de l'extrême droite il racontait à
l'heure du déjeuner qu'il avait poliment
écouté à la mcl obligé parce qu'il ya eu
un communiqué du bureau politique
f de demander la démission démission qui
n'aura pas des consignes n'en appliquer
une conclusion qui se généralise à l'udf
pour les centristes
le moment est apparemment produit
françois bayrou propose ce soir et à
moins que la création d'un nouveau parti
notre conviction est qu'il faut
maintenant construire issu de l'udf
rassemblement politique nouveau où se
retrouveront les démocrates les
républicains
les libéraux s'engageant à refuser tout
accommodement avec l'extrémisme
certains parlent déjà de la mort de
l'udf que ce soir une chose est sûre le
parti fondé par vge ya 20 ans n'a jamais
été si mal en point et face à ce
charivari françois leuthard qui est
toujours président de l'unef annoncé un
instant qu'il va réunir au plus tôt les
instances dirigeants de son mouvement
laurent fabius le président de
l'assemblée nationale est intervenu cet
après midi dans ce débat pour dire qu'un
noeud coulant a été passée par le front
national et qui l'enserrent le coût de
la république dans cet article publié
par le monde
laurent fabius conclu il faut le couper
l'ancien président giscard d'estaing
propose une réforme d'une loterie
scrutin régional sur le mode des
élections municipales qui donnent la
majorité à la liste arrivée en tête
enfin le président du rpr philippe
seguin s'adresser lui ce soir aux jeunes
bière père il estime que le mouvement
gaulliste finalement est sorti de cette
épreuve la tête haute
véronique simple yves pierre emmanuel
traxel totalement sur la veine il je
crois que la lie la conduite du rpr a
été exemplaire pendant les élections
régionales
la nuit mais la france sans forcément
tomber
ce sont 10 au terme d'une semaine folle
ils ont voulu se retrouver discuter mais
surtout entendre parler de l'avenir
ces jeunes du rpr tous fiers de la
transigeant adopter à l'égard du front
national par leur chef de file
pour philippe séguin l'occasion rêvée
aux sorties d'une crise de rappeler que
dans la confusion le rpr a su malgré les
tensions tenir la ligne et affirmer ses
valeurs et afficher son identité sur son
double oui décidément il y avait bien
place entre l'extrême droite et la
gauche plurielle dont une force
politique qui ne pactise ni avec lui ni
avec l'autre
ils sont allés porter nos idées les
mettre à l'épreuve sur le terrain dans
les circonscriptions dans les villes
dans les cités dans les quartiers
maintenant à expliquer et défendre un
véritable projet la crédibilité est à ce
prix une manifestation ce soir à orléans
devant le siège du conseil régional
président depuis la semaine dernière par
l'udf bernard harang élu grâce aux voix
du front national contre la vie du chef
de file régional rpr udf olivier caroff
gregor partis syndicats associations
c'est toute la gauche qui avait appelé à
manifester contre les accords entre la
droite et le front national
mais les élus de la gauche plurielle sa
fille qu'aujourd'hui il pourrait compter
sur un bon port plus que symbolique
et conseiller régional udf ceux qui me
demandent la démission du président du
conseil régional lui aussi du dr il
avait une occasion formidable de partir
avec encore un peu d'honneur c'était de
partir après l'appel du vendor la
république il est obligé de partir
maintenant sous la pression de la rue
tant pis pour lui droite et gauche
ensemble donc en tête de cortège mais
pas question de parler de front
républicain simplement de valeurs
communes
cette alliance est la gauche est
toujours les bouchers sur la valeur nous
refusons ensemble agissements principale
cible bernard ans le président du
conseil régional
non seulement il a été élu grâce aux
voix du fn
mais il est prêt à gérer avec la
religion et c'est cette décision qui
provoque la colère de la plupart des
manifestants
une mobilisation qui prouve que la messe
est loin d'être dite
pour ceux qui veulent faire barrage au
front national le fait est acquis depuis
plusieurs mois mais la date qui restera
dans les livres d'histoire sir à celle
du 25 mars 1998 à ce jour onze pays de
l'union européenne ont officiellement
obtenu le droit de participer au
lancement de la nouvelle monnaie
européenne l'euro qui sera en place au
1er janvier 1990 le sel
yannick revanche les pays qualifiés pour
l'euro un secret de polichinelle pour la
presse un patient et les autres un
secret pourtant bien gardé
l'idée est de le diffuser l'information
les chiffres les cours les diagrammes
au même moment à tout le monde dans le
monde entier onze pays sur cave
sélectionnés par la commission
européenne
c'est désormais officiel c'est écrit
noir sur blanc aux pays remplisse les
critères de maastricht
la france l'allemagne l'autriche la
finlande les pays bas le luxembourg
l'irlande l'espagne et le portugal la
belgique et l'italie deux pays pourtant
très endettés entre dans le club
la commission récompense ainsi leurs
efforts l'euro est sur des rails
satisfaction générale d'helsinki à rome
en passant par paris
7 heures
succès vous référencer réussite que les
français doivent à leur courage leur
détermination
le ruisseau torna en l'absence de quatre
pays de l'union le 1er janvier prochain
la grande bretagne et le danemark ne
veulent pas y participer pas maintenant
la suède n'est pas tout à fait prête et
la grèce est loin de respecter tous les
critères
j moins 280 pour l'euro la mise en
oeuvre de la monnaie unique semble
désormais irréversible 41 ans jour pour
jour après la signature du traité de
rome l'acte fondateur de l'europe
imposée l'euro à plus de 300 millions
d'européens a été une affaire de longue
haleine qui suscite encore bien des
passions et des oppositions dans ces
derniers mois un homme s'est battu comme
un beau diable pour empêcher que la
ferme capote au dernier moment où ne
soit repoussée c'est un français yves
thibault de silguy commissaire européen
chargé justement du lancement de la
venue me tromper chapelle métallique à
la pomme n'est pas est un fruit
universel une pomme de malraux ça comme
la pomme au reste du monde nous laissera
une monnaie universelle
même à l'heure du goûter il ne pense
qu'à ça depuis trois ans
thibault de silguy et le défenseur
acharné de la monnaie unique
leveaux élèves de la commission de
bruxelles arrive toujours le premier à
la grand messe du mercredi
musique au coeur de la puissante
administration le président apprécie son
obstination sur le plan humain sa
principale qualité à votre avis
et c'est sa ténacité pour sa bretagne
il aurait aimé se présenter aux
élections régionales plus fort que tout
l'avènement de l'euro leur tient à
bruxelles comme seuls quelques anciennes
médailles et moi nous de son engagement
politique
les dalles qui date de mon passage à
matignon quand j'étais chez monsieur
chirac chez monsieur balladur sur
l'unique programme aujourd'hui l'union
monétaire onze pays sont pressentis le
commissaire vérifie que les critères
économiques de ces pays convergent
réellement et pour qu'ils sont bien
sages qui est bon pour l'euro est bon
pour l'emploi qui vont diminuer ses
déficits publics
selon nous le montrent pas le chômage on
crée les emplois offerts mois une idée
généralement acquise en france où quand
on diminue les déficits publics
cela augmente le chômage changement de
décor à yoff sommet des 15 ministres des
finances en guise d'interlude les
britanniques ont organisé une visite du
musée local mais on préfère
s'enorgueillir des premières pièces
frappées par les twittos que d'envisager
les conséquences nord sud le roulèr ya 7
millions de citoyens britanniques qui
viennent tous les ans le continent et
puis en 2002 ce seront les seuls accords
définitifs devront trouver courir pour
qui viendront sur le continent après une
banque pour pouvoir changer leur journée
je crois que ça se passe de commentaire
les manifestants sont pourtant bien des
séries quand même à faire entendre leurs
commentaires centre européen pour le
breton persévérant il reste encore
quelques personnes a condamné jeudi
mohsini qui sera l'invité de marie
pierre farkas demain dans les 4 vérités
à 7h50 la société automobile peugeot
citroën a présenté aujourd'hui ses
comptes même si les ventes ont atteint
un chiffre record l'an dernier 2 million
cent mille véhicules vendus pour la
dernière année président de jacques
calvet l'entreprise affiche un déficit
de 2 milliards 8 en janvier 93 d'un
camion citerne dans les freins avaient
lâché avait provoqué un carambolage près
de bourgoin jallieu dans l'isère
plusieurs véhicules s'étaient embrasées
une maison avec prisches au total dix
morts dont le chauffeur emploie
aujourd'hui dans le box des accusés six
personnes le patron de l'entreprise de
poids lourds et les collègues du
chauffeur qui devront s'expliquer sur
l'état du pirée curtet chaque gare
elle le pardon des familles n'est pas
possible
mieux on l'aura bolivie l'expert à la
barre ne fait pas de détail l'ensemble
du système de freinage de la remorque
était et labrie martèlera-t-il ou encore
les freins de fonctionner qu'à 30 % de
leurs capacités
même si le papa ne seront pas dû arriver
là complètement perdu dix membres de
notre famille accident j'attends ce
moment mon fils est mort dans des
conditions
en prime le bras croiser mon choix est
fait la cabine de son camion
on attendait 25 minutes les secours le
point noura premier 10,1 à matri a été
instantanément braz et au milieu du
village béni pain le véhicule avait
pourtant entamé à 10 ans à très faible
mais de kilomètres plus bas il était à
plus de cent kilomètres c'est quelque
chose de grave
et les sites et effroyable de
qualificatif tellement c'était un
village meurtri
aujourd'hui la signalisation des trains
le travail le nombre de poids lourds a
diminué de 50% estiment les habitants
mais la tâche le routier à mme raby et
la gamme x
on y accuse la police française de lui
avoir infligé de graves sévices pendant
sa garde à vue dans un commissariat à
bobigny en région parisienne son cas a
été porté devant la cour européenne des
droits de l'homme le plaignant et qui a
la double nationalité hollandaise et
marocaine occupe actuellement une peine
de 13 ans pour trafic de drogue
un gendarme de 41 ans était tuée hier
soir dans la commune de lussan dans le
gard ses collègues grièvement blessé les
deux hommes ont été victimes d'un
échange de tirs avec un marginal qui
lui-même a été sérieusement blessé au
cours de l'échangé en partenariat avec
le magazine nouvel observateur le banc
d'essai des lycées français à paraître
demain 2234 établissements
d'enseignement général ou technique
privé public
parmi eux nous avons choisi trois lycées
qui ont été remarquées de à paris en
province enquête
jean bernard schmid tant mieux car nos
will grand chalon culture du bruit ou
montaigne derrière six facettes de lycée
se fabriquent les lie ces établissements
ont chaque année presque 100 % de
réussite au bac mais ici ça ne suffit
pas ce qui compte c'est le nombre très
élevé de mention les plus prestigieux de
tous
le lycée henri iv dans le 5e
arrondissement de paris comme chaque
fois il figure en tête du palmarès
un classement qui prend en compte le
taux de réussite à l'examen il est
capacité d'un lycée amener ses élèves de
la seconde au bac les à henri iv
on ne prend sur dossier que les
meilleurs ils exigent sont toujours
paralysés - on écoute ici la sélection
est une tradition que l'on assume
pleinement car elle se fonde uniquement
sur la qualité des élèves que cette
sélection est une bonne chose comme la
sélection de classe préparatoire est une
bonne chose
je pense que nous sommes un certain
nombre s'il n'y avait pas eu les
concours et une 6e place
étant donné nos origines sociales à ne
pas arriver à certains postes de
responsabilité le palmarès des lycées
qui a 100 produits ne veut pas en
entendre parler
il dirige le lycée molière le moins bien
cotés des établissements du 16e
arrondissement
78 % de réussite au bac un livret
ordinaire alors que ses voisins qui sont
excellents selon lui les classements
créé avant tout inclus mais de rivalités
entre les établissements et ça
entretient dès le départ un système
sélectif de concurrence à l'intérieur de
l'établissement à la grée des classes
pour des élèves de 15 16 ans c'est trop
jeune et pas large au niveau des
concurrents c'est normal ils sont pas
des concours au niveau de la présidence
ce n'est pas normal de ma carrière je
sache je fais pas un gourou qui écoute
dans cette salle quinze élèves
approfondissent leur cours de maths
comme chaque semaine les secondes du
lycée denis mourillon près de poitiers
sont divisés en petits groupes c'est qui
permet aux professeurs de se pencher sur
chaque
c'est l'une des clips mais la réussite
de cet établissement démonstration cette
courbe représente l'évolution du
pourcentage de reçus au baccalauréat
depuis 1992
et on peut constater que les
pourcentages sont passées de 66 % à 80 %
sélection concurrence veine ou inconnus
dans cet établissement situé en zone
rurale le lycée de montmorillon
accueille des enfants d'ouvriers et
d'employés
il figure en bonne place dans le
palmarès parce qu'il joue à fond son
rôle d'ascenseur social ici l'échec
scolaire n'est jamais une fatalité
l'objectif est de mener les élèves de
seconde au baccalauréat que ce soir en
trois quatre ou cinq ans notre vue qui
fait également d'accepter tous les
élèves soient de montmorillon fois des
environs soi même qui ont été dénombrés
police et pour le faire obtenir le
baccalauréat un croyez tout neuf
de très nombreux voyages à l'étranger au
lycée jean moulin
on veille aussi au cadre de vie l
ouverture sur l'extérieur les éléments
essentiels
aucun palmarès ne prend en compte l
instant sur le problème des présidences
de conseil régional ou les présidents
d'edf ont été élu grâce aux voix du
front national
première démission ce soir de monsieur
jean pierre soisson président de la
région bourgogne qui a annoncé qu'il
démissionnait de la présidence de région
mais qu'il allait se représenter dans
d'autres conditions
l'actualité internationale le drame hier
dans une petite ville de l'arkansas aux
états unis deux garçons de 12 et 13 ans
ont planifié et exécuté avec des armes
un massacre dans une école qui a fait
cinq morts parmi les élèves et biblis
parmi les explications avancées une
réprimande main accepté dans les jours
précédant fr ou encore un problème de
coeur ce drame intervient au moment où
les américains ont pris connaissance
d'une statistique sur la violence dans
le milieu scolaire qui a connu une très
forte augmentation l'an dernier
washington parents élèves ont veillé une
partie de la nuit devant l' école de
jonesboro c'est la stupeur
le pays est choquée comme cet enfant
blessé qui a vu sa vie basculer sortir
et retourner dans cette école
j'étais à l'amérique est fatigué de voir
régulièrement un drapeau en berne devant
une école et les grands moyens utilisés
ne change rien les établissements
scolaires sont devenus le pré carré des
bandes et des gangs
il faut se rendre à l'évidence l'école
est le reflet de la ville de la rue et
si le crime
regrettes chez les adultes est souvent
en augmentation très sensible chez les
jeunes
même les très jeunes selon une enquête
commandée par la maison blanche
une école sur dix a été le cadre de
graves violences l'année dernière les
jeunes dans un environnement emilia de
la violence partout crée le même
phénomène avec les autres jeunes si vous
ajoutez à ça la violence les médias ça
n'est peut-être pas là et ça peut
pousser les personnes prédisposées
enfin évidemment l'accès aux armes
l'argent ira afin de juguler la violence
le président a conseillé entre autres le
port de l'uniforme pour éviter les
différences les enseignants sont pour
elle en a pas de surenchère haut débit
leurs chaussures des meilleurs si les
new york la veille il ne faut pas
oublier qu'en amérique la violence est
renforcée par les armes à feu la police
ont saisi tous les jours on peut
facilement s'en procurer la peine qu'on
corps d'armes et de cinq ans pas assez
dissuasive
le rapport commandé par le président
clinton indique qu'il y aurait eu l'an
dernier 4000 viol ou agression sexuelle
dans les écoles et 11000 attaque à main
armée à bonn le groupe de contact des
pays européens accorder à la serbie un
délai de quatre semaines
des solutions supplémentaires un répit
pour engager des négociations avec la
majorité albanaise de la province du
post sur le terrain bien les
affrontements continuent de faire des
morts selon une formule malheureusement
bien établie désormais manifestations
répressions policières
reportage au romancier jacques ils sont
venus ce matin par petits groupes pour
voir les dégâts les hommes uniquement
les femmes sont encore trop peur
certains sont venus des villages voisins
en simple curieux tofu remporter ce qui
peut être encore sauvée de leurs maisons
détruits
nous sommes à claude chan le village où
s'est concentré hier l'assaut de la
police serbe après que ceux qu'ils
appellent les terroristes albanais et
tué un de leurs collègues partout la
trace de combat sont encore visibles
alors quand même des trucs comme ça il y
en a partout autour des six mois
certaines maisons détruites brûle encore
cet homme nous raconte que l'attak a
commencé à 11h au début il était là mais
il a réussi à fuir avec sa famille il
nous dit aussi qu'il ne comprend pas
pourquoi la police s'est acharné sur sa
maison la plupart des habitants ne sont
pas encore revenus et ce matin à
pristina les policiers ont tenu à
montrer à la presse les armes qui les
auraient saisi dans les maisons investi
au même instant dans les rues de la
ville une manifestation de femmes
dénoncer la violence et en appeler à la
communauté internationale provocation
côté albanais répression violente côté
serbe manifestation dans les rues de
christina le cycle de la violence c'est
donc répéter une fois de plus hier au
kosovo aujourd'hui si la tension est
légèrement retombé dans les villages qui
ont subi l'assaut des forces de police
se calme on est évidemment qu'à part en
auto en france avec le salon du livre
qui ferme ses portes ce soir chaque
année des enfants particulièrement
méritants ils sont invités par le
magazine the book ligne qui organise un
concours
dans tous les établissements scolaires
de france sur départ un scénario un
début scénario présenté par un écrivain
célèbre aux enfants ensuite d'écrire le
livre les gagnants cette année une
classe de 6ème d'agen qui prouve que les
petits français s'intéressent à la
lecture reportage geneviève moll à
l'arrivée des tgv à peu prendre ce train
pour la première fois et à les découvrir
paris mais tous avaient les cheveux
flous même leur prof de français ne me
reconnaît joseph chaumié agen
les 24 élèves de la 6ème tac ont
travaillé pendant dix semaines sur le
texte d'un auteur très connu les enfants
daniel pennac mellac raconte à rentrer
d'une place de matt à laquelle le prince
dit qu'il retient le nom de ses élèves
en les classant par groupe l'écran les
petits les blonds les bras mais l'un
d'entre eux n'entre dans aucune de ces
catégories il sera l'élève qui a perdu
ton dos les impôts de 26 une traque ont
refusé en bloc de vivre le texte de
penaltys oubliés ils devaient pas
appliquer cette crise il est allé d'un
jeune femme nancy pourtant on est tous
différent une chose qui cloche
quel est votre différence parce qu'on
est tous pareils différents cette
histoire écrite par toutes les classes
chacun a fait nos propres livres avec
une couverture bien et où tout le monde
a sa façon participer chaque oeil avec
sa personnalité je crois et le pécule
vraiment un reflet de cette classe qui
est comme un peu ce mail unifiée
terminer ce travail les élèves de 5e du
collège de saint lô vu la tour eiffel il
rencontré daniel pennac
et le café littéraire de la fnac au
salon du livre l'artiste a même été lu
par un comédien tous du nouveau à
contribuer au lendemain matin en cours
de maths
monsieur à rennes a vu débouler dans sa
classe
une troupe de clown je veux rose fluo
chaussures de clown et gonflées comme
des bibendums
une vie et une ironie le manque j'ai
bien aimé pays comment de voir tous ces
enfants comme ils ont une vision des
choses et du monde futur et dans leur
tête
alors un jour mais surtout l'artiste va
être publiés le plus internet
l'an passé il faut qu'elle se libérèrent
match de préparation pour la coupe du
monde de football cet après-midi la
france a mal commencé son match contre
la russie erreur de dégagement
la rue
rens
pensez même pas
n'ont pas réussi à revendre
dégagement du gardien de but france et
puis ce soir en direct sur france 2 la
rencontre des deux favoris de la
prochaine coupe du monde l'allemagne
d'europe contre le brésil le champion du
monde
lang le tronc philibert il venait à
tomber quoi l'état civil et les joueurs
ne sont pas encore sur le terrain mais
lui est déjà en direct depuis dix
minutes sur une radio brésilienne
un millier de supporters 400 reporters
partout le brésil passe la magie opère
et les affaires prospèrent et demi du
revêtement ne bouge pas une oreille sans
l'accord de leur sponsor américain et
l'entraînement a lieu sous haute
sécurité
heureusement il reste le terrain les
artistes et leur prodigieuse habileté
aujourd'hui on en a besoin parce que
c'est ça le d90 et qui n'attendent pas
le charme et le charme magique
la série entre charme et éthique la cité
entre spectacle et rigueur le brésil
cherche son équilibre pour calmer les
supporters mécontents des derniers
matches de la sélection on a même
rappelé ico l'ancien joueur au poste
d'entraîneur adjoint
sicaud sur le banc ronaldo sont de
terrain les artistes associés ont pour
première mission de battre l'allemagne
le choc allemagne brésil aura donc eu
ici au gottlieb daimler stadion
stuttgart
c'est qu'une opposition royal en pro le
dernier champion d'europe l'allemagne et
le champion du monde en titre le brésil
c'est aussi l'opposition de deux
prochains favoris pour le mondial en
france et au mois de juin prochain à
paris en marge de la compétition
officielle se déroulera une autre coupe
du monde de football celle des banlieues
quatre équipes de jeunes ont été
sélectionnés viendront mexique d'afrique
du sud du brésil au brésil pays où le
football vous savez est roi ce sport est
la base d'un système d'insertion des
jeunes en difficulté c'est le héros
national pelé en personne qui a lancé ce
programme
reportage olivier lisa raymond chaplin
quelque part au brésil un enfant pauvre
rêve de s'évader dans sa chambre lui
imagine un voyage impossible
un voyage en europe en france pour
participer à la coupe du monde le
football
la clé du voyage la clé du rêve j'aime
c'est agréable
c'est bon pour la santé ça c'est une
façon de vivre qui peut m'amener à être
connu à réussir comme tous les
footballeurs bayane et qui sont devenus
professionnels
djouzi 14 ans vit avec sa maman dans une
petite maison de feira de santana feira
de santana une ville une banlieue de
500000 habitants perdue à 200 km de
salvador de bahia
des milliers d'enfants qui s'amuse avec
native qui joue avec l'ennui les enfants
aux prises avec la délinquance ont
croisé problème d'éducation
leur seule oasis un centre qui accueille
4500 jeunes bonjour à tous comme vous le
savez nous sommes en période de
préparation débat aujourd'hui aux
problèmes techniques et physiques et va
pas de soi sans nous allons participer à
la coupe du monde
nous devons le faire avec respect
l'humilité la coupe du monde et banlieue
pour une quinzaine de footballeurs âgés
de moins de 13 ans issus de milieux
défavorisés
ma vie était très difficile mon père
était au chômage pour vivre attendait du
pain qu'ils fabriquaient la maison
ailleurs un jour j'ai été invité à
participer à ce projet le projet sport
solidarité créée il ya deux ans par
l'ancien footballeur pelé ce programme
était évident raté cas du brésil
objectif permettre à des enfants de
retrouver une place dans la société par
le quai du football brésilien dit
l'artiste finances avec un ennemi
imaginaire et qui s'entraînent comme des
virtuoses
ma vie a changé
aujourd'hui je fréquente des gens
corrects les trois qui ne m'amène pour
problème
aujourd'hui on a les gants avant à
l'école j'avais une mauvaise note
maintenant je travaille je m'assois
premier rang et je suis toujours le
premier le sentier de la gloire
quatre heures de vol le matin écoles la
famille des travaux d'utilité collective
le soir les enfants cultivent eux mêmes
une partie de leur nourriture lampes de
poches masque en matière de sport dans
notre centre est un outil socio éducatif
nous souhaitons que tous les services
futurs et qu'il retrouve une haute
estime
la journée terminée en use it
la majorité des enfants retournent chez
eux les plus pauvres dans tout ça
celui qui n'avait pas les moyens de
m'élever alors maintenant que de les
voir un inspecteur de police qui m'a
amené ici limité les idoles en novembre
dernier à rhinau l'examen de feira de
santana se complique on est champion
d'un tournoi de qualification à la coupe
du monde va devoir finalement au le
trophée remis par les le rêve devenu
réalité
les apprentis footballeurs ont donc
trouvé la clé du voyage en juillet
prochain ils iront en france on veut
gagner la coupe mais l'essentiel est
ailleurs des enfants défavorisés par
david et peut-être que vous trouvez un
espoir un espoir
baum a validé principaux titres de
l'actualité de ce mercredi la première
démission d'un président
demain